[Musique]
on dit de l'est du kentucky que c'est
l'endroit aux états unis où il est le
plus difficile de vivre ce qu'il reste
du charbon c'est un taux de chômage
fracassant un mal de vivre une culture
de dépendance aux médicaments souvent
prescrit aux mineurs pour soulager leurs
mots et leurs maladies ce mâle s'est
installé s'est propagé dans des comtés
comme celui de roanne
on ne parle même plus d'une crise née
d'une véritable catastrophe
personne n'y échappe surtout pas les
enfants allen avait 6 ans quand elle a
compris à quel point minutes comment
peuvent tuer leur sexe nhl
et eux en s'écroulant celui qu'il a
élevé son beau père est mort d'une
surdose d'oxycodone c'est elle qui l'a
découvert allongé dans son lit que ses
enfants comme l'ena sont devenus ce
qu'on appelle aux états unis les
orphelins des opiacés ils sont des
milliers dont les parents sont soit
morts soit incarcéré ou tout simplement
incapables d'élever leurs petits jazz
mme n'a que 10 ans elle ne sait pas
quand ou si elle reverra un jour sa
maman
avril au nord mais elle sait que c'est à
cause de la drogue qu'elle a été
abandonnée au moment où elle sa soeur et
son frère étaient carrément négliger
souvent ils allaient au lit à femme et
sa grand mère laura c'est elle qui va
les élever une réalité à laquelle de
plus en plus grands parents sont
confrontés aussi a pris en charge ses
trois petits-enfants leur père et leur
mère ont été tous les deux condamnés à
10 et 12 en prison
tous les jours après l'école ces enfants
viennent ici aux boys and girls club de
harley le club de loisirs est devenue
avec les années un refuge un lieu
sécuritaire où rien ne peut leur arriver
si nous étions ouverts 24 heures les
enfants il resterait 24 heures dit la
directrice katina elle dit que tous dans
la pièce subissent les contrecoups de la
descente aux enfers
le père de charlie a commencé à prendre
des antidouleurs prescrit pour combattre
la dépression
les rangers et lucian a été confiée à
ses grands parents avec son petit frère
le médecin vous lui prescrire des
médicaments mais la famille a refusé le
plus inquiétant c'est que tous ces
enfants sont aussi à risque de
développer une dépendance et les efforts
déployés pour les protéger sont sans
précédent définie ci en tout l'est du
kentucky pour rencontrer les enfants et
faire de la prévention
ces petites trousses de dépistage seront
distribués à des milliers de foyers pour
tester si les enfants
on se mit même des opiacés il nous
confie que lui-même s'occupe de du petit
orphelin
c'est devenu la norme et elle est
troublant
[Musique]
newzoo quand on entre chez nous si nos
pays on se croirait dans une petite gare
de ris outre le fond c'est une famille
d'accueil
il avait déjà trois enfants puis ils ont
pris en charge
pierre laisné skyler ils ont adopté
benegas à cinq ans
c'est l'aîné qui prenait soin de sa
soeur leur mère n'était jamais là elle a
perdu la garde pour de bon incapable de
surmonter sa dépendance ou kentucky
seulement 9000 enfants ont été placés en
famille d'accueil cette année où
attendent de l'être si 3000 de plus
qu'il ya cinq ans il y manque encore
deux places
n'eut été de sa grand mère jazmine aussi
serait sur une liste d'attenté un mois
mais sa mère lui manque terriblement
[Musique]
quand on demande à harly si elle a
espoir que ses parents s'en sortent par
maman elle répond que pour sa mère il
est trop tard elle rêve ou jour où elle
aura 18 ans pour pouvoir quitter rennes
avec son frère et oublier son enfance
[Musique]
c'est lourd à porter quand on a 15 ans
il aura fallu en arriver là toute une
génération sacrifiée pour que les états
unis déclare enfin l'état d'urgence
[Musique]